despite El Caminos efforts to provide
closure for summer Breaking Bad's few
lingering questions there are still a
few loose ends remaining at the end here
are all the biggest questions that were
still asking after El Camino of Breaking
Bad movie
although Walt's wife Skyler spent the
first couple seasons of Breaking Bad
unaware of his illegal dealings she
eventually joined him on the dark side
when she began helping Walt to launder
his money by the end of the series the
pragmatic Skyler was up to her ears and
illicit activity adding tax fraud and
obstruction of justice to her crimes in
addition to suggesting that Walt have
Jesse Pinkman kill you need to deal with
this how much have you had to drink
not nearly enough in the finale Walt
gave Skyler a lottery ticket with the
coordinates for the location where the
bodies of Hank Schrader and Steve Gomez
were buried thinking she could trade the
information for immunity however that's
the last we ever see of Skyler an El
Camino never mentions what became of her
we have no way of knowing whether Walt's
last attempt to help his family paid off
or whether the bodies of two dead DEA
agents was a big enough bargaining chip
to get Skyler off the hook for her
criminal misdeeds realizing that every
penny he ever made selling meth would
likely get seized by the DEA once they
finished amassing evidence against them
Walt decides to give his money to his
family via a more circuitous route
visiting the luxurious home of his
former business partners elliott's and
Gretchen Schwartz Walt gives them the
9.7 two million dollars he managed to
hold on to after the rest of his fortune
was seized by Uncle Jack and his gang of
white supremacists he instructs them to
set up a trust for his son Walt Jr which
will be given to him on his 18th
birthday as a gift from the Schwartz's
Walt then threatens them that if they
failed to carry out his instructions he
has hired assassins to have them killed
however at Walt Jr's birthday was still
10 months away at the end of Felina and
El Camino leaves us with no way of
knowing whether the Schwartz's carried
out their end of the bargain we do know
that Walt's assassins were actually just
badgering skinny Pete with laser
pointers so there wouldn't be any
consequences if the Schwartz's decided
to keep the money whether Gretchen and
Elliott figured that out though we may
never know after Hank discovers the
truth about Walt and arrests him his
wife Marie seems to relish forcing her
sister to tell Walt Jr the truth about
Walt
however Marie climbs off her high horse
to support her sister when Walt calf
baby Holly only to be devastated again
when she learns that Hank is killed the
last contact we seen between Marie and
Skyler is in the finale when Marie calls
to warn Skyler that Walt's is back in
town and cautions her to stay wary and
safe it's implied during the
conversation that the sisters haven't
spoken in months while the relationship
between Skyler and Marie wasn't always
the best they seemed fairly close in the
early seasons living nearby and seeing
each other often it's probably safe to
assume that their relationship will
never be the same following the finale
however will never see whether their
relationship continued to heal or was
severed for good since neither sister is
seen or mentioned in El Camino in polina
Walter White spends a lot of time paying
back the people who have wronged him but
one of his most elaborate revenge
schemes involves his judgement on Lydia
rodarte-quayle Lydia tries to conspire
against Walt when he comes back to town
but Walt is several steps ahead and uses
her own habits against her by poisoning
the stevia she always used in her tea
the last we saw Lydia she was looking
significantly under the weather when she
called Todd thinking that her plan to
kill Walt had been successfully carried
out soon after Walt tells her that not
only had her plan failed but that her
illness was in fact the first stages of
ricin poisoning while Breaking Bad
implied that Lydia was doomed El Camino
reveals that her fate may still be up in
the air at one point Jesse here's a
radio news report that mentions a
Houston woman with possible ties to
Walter White's is in the hospital in
critical condition and not expected to
survive
however while her odds don't look great
we'll never know for sure if Walt was
successful in his attempt to get rid of
her bye Lydia one of the most
heartwarming parts of El Camino comes
right at the beginning when a
traumatized Jesse turns to two of the
only allies he has left his longtime
friends skinny Pete and badger
however after Pete Badger helped Jesse
they hit a snag when they attempt to get
rid of the El Camino that jesse was
driving the LoJack was activated meaning
the police will arrive at Pete's house
soon jesse offers to drive the El Camino
away from the house but skinny Pete has
another plan badger will abandon Pete's
car near the Mexican border Jesse will
escape in Badgers car and Pete will
remain at his house with the El Camino
Pete and Badger also give Jesse all the
money they have
on them after Jessie and Badger drive
off Pete moves the El Camino to the
front of his driveway and waits for the
police to arrive showing that he has
nothing to hide
while the teaser for El Camino seemed to
pick up after this with Pete's and the
police station the film itself never
shows either of Jesse's friends again we
can only hope that Pete and Badger get
to go home and keep working on their
Star Trek spec script I ever tell you
about my Star Trek script Star Trek
yeah I got it write it down is all the
enterprise in the penultimate scene of
El Camino as Jesse prepares to embark on
his new life in Alaska ed the disappear
asked him if there is anything else
Jesse needs to take care of before the
to part ways
Jesse hands him a letter which edy reads
over and then promises the mail from
Mexico City in a month as Jesse drives
away the camera reveals that the letter
is addressed to Brock can taeho
neither of them discussed what Jesse
wrote in his final missive to Brock
although we can guess that at least part
of his note was a farewell the rest is
left up to our imaginations
perhaps Jesse tried to offer some sort
of explanation or apology for what
happened to his mother it's also
possible that Jesse used some of the
money he took from Neel candy to help
provide for Brock's future similar to
the trust Walt managed to set up for his
son we may never know what Jesse's final
words to Brock were but no matter what
he wrote we're sure it came from parts
the last we saw of saul goodman's
intimidating bodyguard Huell Babineaux
toward the end of Breaking Bad he was
sitting in a DEA safehouse patiently
awaiting the return of Hank Schrader and
Steve Gomez unfortunately for everyone
Hank and Steve were killed by Jack
Welker and his gang shortly thereafter
so they would never return to the
safehouse to advise Hewell on next steps
according to series creator Vince
Gilligan
Huell would have eventually been found
questioned and ultimately released by
other DEA agents but that's not really
good enough for fans who hope to see
Hugh olds fate definitively addressed in
Canon the official Breaking Bad Facebook
page took it one step further sharing a
video of Huell getting up and leaving
the safehouse to coincide with the
release of El Camino still he will fail
to get a cameo or even a mention in the
movie itself even if we consider the
Facebook video part of the film all it
establishes is that Hugh will eventually
left the safehouse we have no idea where
he went or what he's up to now an El
Camino doesn't give us any clues the
other long-suffering employee in the
Office of Saul Goodman and associates is
Francesca Liddy who we last saw toward
the end of Breaking Bad
season when she was held at gunpoint by
Jesse Pinkman
although hue old was later picked up by
the DEA we never learned what became a
Francesca after Saul fled Albuquerque
and Saul Goodman & Associates was no
more in the Breaking Bad spinoff series
better call Saul we learned that
Francesca was once a bright-eyed and
enthusiastic former employee of New
Mexico's Motor Vehicle Division somehow
over her years working Saul she became
jaded and cynical we wondered whether we
might see her pop up in El Camino but
the former receptionist accomplished
didn't receive a mention in the Jesse
centric tale
we're not sure what professional
opportunities are out there for a
secretary who spent the last decade of
her life working for a shady criminal
lawyer who's currently wanted by the DEA
still better call Saul did leave us with
a few clues for where Francesca goes
after the events of Breaking Bad in the
spin-off we see that Saul gives
Francesca the business card of a lawyer
from his Jimmy McGill days we may find
out what happened to Francesca in an
upcoming season of BCS for the viewers a
better call Saul we've gotten a small
glimpse into what Saul Goodman formerly
known as Jimmy McGill is up to following
the events of Breaking Bad the last we
saw him in Breaking Bad Saul was
preparing to embark on a new life in
Nebraska courtesy of at the disappeared
and better call Saul we see that in his
new life Saul is known as Jean and he
works at a Cinnabon in Omaha still
afraid of the enemies he made through
his association with Walt
Jean lives in a constant state of
anxiety and paranoia while we may
eventually get a more complete picture
of what Saul's life looks like following
Breaking Bad El Camino didn't offer up
any clues the only obscure nod to Saul
Goodman is a brief shot of the strip
mall that once housed his law office
which has since been turned into a
sports bar neither jesse nor ed ever
discussed what became of the disgraced
former lawyer and although better call
saul fills in the blanks a little bit
there's still plenty we don't know about
Saul's life following Breaking Bad but
if there's one thing we know about Saul
Goodman it's that as much as he may
insist that he's left his former life
behind him he won't be able to keep his
nose clean for long throughout Breaking
Bad although it was never stated
outright it was always implied that
Jesse Pinkman dropped out of high school
before graduating we knew that he failed
mr. White's chemistry class as a junior
yet Jesse's parents still considered
Walt one of Jesse's better teachers
implying that his happen chemistry was
not an anomaly on his report card
however in El Camino Walt comments that
Jesse might try
College suggesting a business and
marketing degree as a counter to Jesse's
proposal of Sports Medicine
but first Walt says Jesse would have to
get his GED to which Jesse responds that
he doesn't need a GED because he already
has a high school diploma yo you're
standing right on stage when they handed
it I know and to slip my mind
I totally graduated high school of
course now that Jesse has a new identity
in Alaska as mr. trisko he likely won't
be using his degree from JP Wynn high
school on his application but that
doesn't mean he can't continue his
education under his new name if jesse
pinkman had a completed high school
education then so does mr. trisko
and although few of Walter White's ideas
ever seem to be in Jesse's best interest
this one might be el camino' doesn't
tell us what happens to Jesse once he
arrives in Alaska but it's nice to think
that if we were to catch up with him at
some point in the distant future we
might find him with the successful
career in sports medicine if not that
maybe he can major in check out one of
our newest videos right here Plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]